now you had this period of time where
you were working on the TV show punked
yes and I'm fascinating that was my
first on-camera job and that was just
still my favorite job I've ever had and
why was it your favorite job because I
love pranks I've always loved pranks
that's my version of you know Mindy lies
I actually do the work right right she
can just say oh that person sends his
Flemish armor but I love pranks and here
was a job where a professional team set
up the prank for you and you just knock
the pins down it was unbelievable and
Ashton Kutcher you know this was my
first I was 23 24. I had only been in
the writer's room I'd started doing
stand-up a couple years ago I suddenly
got some heat as a stand up I killed my
audition and I'm here with Ashton
Kutcher who loomed so large especially
at that moment now he's sort of an icon
that has graduated he's been on forever
but he was just bursting yeah like cover
People magazine every week so cool and
um I was like this comedy writer still
wearing the kind of pleated khakis that
you wear when you grow up in Boston and
he was like in my earpiece I'm wearing
those right now you [ __ ] what to say
to these pop stars that would freak them
out I mean it was as someone who loved
pranks was a dream come true now your
job as a performer was to play the
reality of the prank yeah it was great
acting training because you have to be
convincing you cannot funny and you get
one take yeah and you cannot indicate
the joke which is uh as everyone knows
who's worked in comedy
actually they don't know it but they
should know it don't indicate the joke
it's it ruins it yes you're indicating
since I've directed comedy a lot of
people show up great actors great
dramatic actors show up ready to do
comedy and they don't realize that by
that philosophy that we both subscribe
to no no play the drama get the comedy
deep down but you play that reality if
you want as soon as you play The Comedy
it's not funny well I think it's
um
what Steve Carell did so brilliantly was
was yeah he's a brilliant actor yes and
he played every moment with complete
honesty yes uh as uh Michael Scott he
could sell you could write him the most
insane
thing for a human being that no human
being grills his foot on a George
Foreman grill because he wants to wake
up to the smell of bacon and then right
tells his office to treat him as a
handicapped person right but when he
performs that you buy it right I see how
a human being could do that and he's not
rubbing his hands before the scene to
say how do I make this funny he I think
he is deep down I think he is a writer
brain that's coming up with the funny
things to say but then his act or heart
is is you know playing the drama of this
human being in this terrible situation
in that character's mind you know when
you uh were doing these pranks on punked
was there ever a moment where because
you can't break I mean you're not
supposed to break in sketches but people
do but if you're if you're part of a
prank and you're pretending to be uh
someone who you know is a barista or
someone who's working the counter at a
restaurant do you know what I mean and
you've got to play that reality and you
can't start giggling or the entire thing
is ruined yeah was that ever a problem
yeah I've almost never I'm actually I
think I'm a little too serious when I do
comedy I think that if you watch The
Office bloopers I'm almost never
breaking and I I wish I had brought
myself to the level of being about to
break a lot because I do think a lot of
great comedy comes at that teetering
Edge but um I didn't generally have a
problem with that but I did watch
something where I saw my face just bite
my cheek to not break and there was one
outrageous I mean some of my Mom hated
punked
um there was one outrageous one where
Rachel Lee Cook was the actor and she
um so they always find like their
vulnerability or their obsession and so
she and Jonathan Tucker who's a friend
of mine now was the the accomplice so he
brought her to a restaurant she
volunteered with the elderly and we got
a stunt man to um to be the waiter like
a forgetful waiter that kept messing up
her order and I was an [ __ ]
um manager of the restaurant that was
abusive to this elderly waiter and
screamed at him for uh messing up the
order and then eventually started
throwing him against the wall because
he's a stunt guy yeah it's so violent
and um
and yeah watching that I laugh now
because I can't believe that we would do
such a thing I mean first of all you
just described my favorite day ever I it
would be a joy for me to beat the
elderly yes well to beat up people it's
so funny because to do these things and
and have to convince someone yes it's
real what you were saying the acting
training is this is amazing because you
have to be funny
um enough to you're improvising because
you're making up the stuff you have to
be completely convincing so the other
person the scene thinks this is the
worst day of their life
um and it's a high wire because you've
one take we I'm not a natural prankster
I don't think that's something that I
was built for I worry a lot that someone
will get hurt or upset apparently was
not my problem I just do not have that
but the couple of times
um in my career that we've uh the
writers have come up with something
where I get to kind of inhabit that
Niche I've been so happy and my writers
came up with something once that's um
was a great idea which is let's get a
really good prosthetic person to make me
up to be a someone who doesn't look
anything like me and then I will run a
focus group that's great to show people
Conan O'Brien
um people who wouldn't really know me
how did you disguise yourself they we
got a really good prosthetic person who
added a lot of weight and age to me and
I did not look like me I don't know if
you remember that I do remember it I
love this and um I
it was I was dealing with a lot of older
people and I was showing them we
intentionally picked stuff from jumping
around or doing the string dance and the
monologue we cut together this thing
that would just look very alienating and
I was showing them this stuff and they
really didn't like it
and they were saying well we don't like
this person and then I started to egg
them on by saying well here is
I don't like to tell Tales out of school
but why would a focus group I did gossip
like that I did but I started to sell it
I started to gossip with them a little
bit about how I heard Conan O'Brien's
not a good guy and they were like what
do you mean and I said well I'm not here
to say things and you didn't hear it
from me and this is just between you me
and the fence post I kept making up
these crazy stupid things this is
between you me and the fence post but
I'll tell you he that I had dated Cher
and then I dumped her and they were like
he dumped Cher and they were livid and
I'm like well again you didn't hear it
but from me you know I was quiet as an
aardvark and an onion but I'll tell you
this much and I was just trying but I
was so happy and I would go on long
tangents and then I would say things
that I heard about Conan O'Brien that
were really kind of not great other
shitty things and I had so much fun and
I understood the joy of getting to do
that yeah getting to be the whole crew
helping you but that's really I mean you
carried that well it was so much fun it
was so much fun but but I understand
because I grew up with Brothers I've
always been someone who likes to Rough
House choose a term probably no one uses
anymore
um because it's just a cute way of
saying physical abuse but I loved
roughhousing still love roughhousing and
so the idea of wait yeah no I will
wrestle you before this is over and
you'll be very uncomfortable Rayne
Wilson always wanted to wrestle with me
yeah during the office I understand that
yeah I I look easy to beat
I think someone hasn't wrestled in while
I was like why don't I start with you
but when then move on to krasinski's
bodyguard whenever I was in a sketch
with people when I was in a sketch that
called for me to to punch someone and
throw them through a wall or for me to
get punched and get thrown through a
wall
to this day even at my age I would sign
up for a second I absolutely love it it
makes me so happy when Show Business
involves being a kid basically I think
that's what it is and when someone like
builds a fake wall I mean it's so great
when a crew goes to such serious effort
to do for you to do something so
ridiculous